from what I'm being told right now in
the last 15 minutes the Chiefs did not
interview Tyree kill because if I don't
interview you you can't lie to me
statement issued by Hill on Thursday
includes an explanation for his lawyers
from his lawyers that he met with law
enforcement officials he did not invoke
his Fifth Amendment rights answered all
the questions and that apparently was
good enough for the Kansas City Chiefs
now the tape comes out yeah Paulie if it
comes out that the Chiefs never sat down
with him to ask him what happened
they're gonna catch a lot of heat but
I'm wondering if the Players Union would
allow a player to speak to management of
a team about a crime like is there
anything where the players union says he
doesn't have to talk to the team
management about any accusations off the
field but if they said that there are no
charges being filed although they said
they think that there was a crime
committed I don't know legality wise or
from the league's perspective if the
Chiefs can sit down Tyree kill and ask
him these questions because if they did
that with Kareem hunt and then the video
came out but you had the DA that they
were investigating this far from over
and I wondered if it was going to change
the Kansas City Chiefs draft strategy
because they traded out of the first
round let me bring in Todd McShea ESPN
NFL draft analyst did it did this or
will it change the Kansas City Chiefs
draft strategy going into rounds two and
three yeah brutal transition I guess it
has to you know you have to plan if
you're you have to kind of separate the
two obviously you know the humanity of
all of it and then the business part of
it and the business part of it is
there's a chance you might be without
one of your best playmakers and if
that's the case and we need to we need
to address it so I you know I'm guessing
that they will they will try to you know
bring in another playmaker just in case
a wide receiver someone who can try to
fill that void or at least play that
position but a good luck doing that and
then be you know good and this is just
it's just a horrible situation yeah
it is and look I I'm sorry I dropped
that on you I just
alright I don't think to be honest with
you I don't think it's getting enough
attention well because of the draft and
I talked to somebody last night with the
Players Association they said you know
what if the draft didn't happen last
night this story would be even bigger
and now you have audio and the fact that
maybe Tyriq Hill that it somehow got
watered down a little bit because of the
draft last night yeah and I don't you
know we none of us know all the details
so it's tough to say it's just hard to
hear some of these things for anyone but
especially I've got two young kids a
four and a half year old three-year-old
I just I can't even I can't even imagine
being anywhere near or anything like
this that formal introduction Todd
McClay ESPN NFL draft analyst there it's
like you you did you join the program
already in progress here Todd okay give
me the draft strategy you loved last
night well first of all I love teams
like Jacksonville Detroit and Buffalo
just kind of sitting tight and waiting
sometimes you gotta wait for others to
make mistakes and I think two mistakes
were made in the first six picks and
Cleveland Perl was one of them and he's
going to be he's a good player but he's
not the fourth overall player in this
graph Josh Allen
Kentucky's a better pass rusher has
better traits for the NFL I I was
surprised by the pick but then again Jon
Gruden falls in love with a player and
he's going to take that player it
doesn't matter if mike Mayock or anyone
else is in the building and then we all
know my feelings on on the quarterback
Daniel Jones going to the Giants but
then you sit there in Jacksonville if
you go through their needs edge rusher
is pretty low on the list but when you
get a player like Josh Allen that falls
to you in that spot at number seven when
you thought maybe he could go three to
the Jets for two to Oakland five to
Tampa you take advantage of it and
that's what they did
Detroit wasn't scared of taking the
tight end who I think is one of the six
best players this class said Hawkins
coming out of Iowa and a guy who's gonna
I think really helped Mathieu
even though that had struggles with the
tight end position before and then and
Oliver falls again another player that I
thought Oakland could have easily taken
at number four and probably should have
taken at number four and they just they
sit home they don't try to get cute and
their biggest need was finding its
difference maker at the defensive tackle
position and and Oliver falls in their
lap so I think those are three of my
favorite things and then I also love
what Denver did to they didn't want to
move out of ten but they knew they
didn't want to take a quarterback in
this class they whether you liked Joe
Flacco or not it makes sense to not
bring to bring in Joe Flacco and then
not bring in a quarterback at number 10
it's just going to create a problem so
let's give Flacco a year see if it works
and in the meantime let's go get a tight
end because he loves to tie that that's
a security blanket it always was in
Baltimore and so they get a tight end
who is a top 15 talent at number 20 plus
they get the fifty to fifty second
overall taking it you know in addition
and then they get the they get a I
believe a second round pick next year so
they they got a lot of stuff to help
them this year and then also for the
future and if the quarterback doesn't
work in Flacco this year now they've got
some more draft capital next year to
maybe move up and go get a guy if Kyler
Murray's not taken by Arizona how far
does he fall great question great
question I'm going to say Oakland I'm
gonna say Oakland it for not knowing for
sure I think I think they really like
him and I every bit of information I've
gotten is that Derek Carr and Jon Gruden
are not made to last in terms of their
merits
so we'll see if that plays out or not
and sometimes you can overcome it but I
at some point I expect Gruden in the
next year or two to probably move in a
different direction and it would not
have shocked me if if Kyler didn't go
number one if it's Oakland took him at
number four because I heard a lot of
information about him just liking Murray
and wanting to kind of become a little
bit more progressive offensively if
Daniel Jones
selected sixth overall how far does he
fall 717 where the Giants are back on
the clock oh well yeah I don't have that
I mean Miami wasn't taking him
Washington was not taking him and then
you know he hasn't been a giant sir at
17 and I don't you know maybe when I
heard the Chargers but then I was told
late last night the Chargers would not
have taken it at 28 maybe it seemed like
New England but I have no information on
that but I I think it was the Giants or
bust in the first round does Josh Rosen
get traded tonight I would say there's a
strong possibility because what what are
your other options if he doesn't get
traded tonight then you're either taking
a really bad deal on a guy that you
traded up for to to take it 10 last year
would you rather up Josh Rosen or Daniel
Jones Josh Rosen all day long
not even close and he's the price Todd
that's what I don't understand that yeah
and I do applaud the Giants if you know
who you want and you get them then get
them I agree I agree and I and
philosophically I am completely on board
with that it don't wait til 17 and don't
try to get you to trade up because you
never know if you can make a deal so I
get I get that part but it's the
evaluation that I have an issue with and
that's why I don't give out grades the
day after because I just look at
philosophy the strategy behind what
you're doing what positions you're going
after and the needs that you have
because a lot of these teams will go hey
is it is it talent over need or vice
versa and then you can critique the
strategy I have no idea what Daniel
Jones is gonna be like in three years
I don't know what Dwayne Haskins is
gonna be like in three years that's the
one position where I can't grade you're
right I don't know what Kyler Murray's
gonna be like Josh Rosen could turn out
to be more productive than him if he
goes to the right place so that's why
when you get to these hey what's the
draft grades that you have for this guy
or these teams it's really hard to do
that yeah I was told by my bosses early
on in my ESPN career that I have a
ceccolini make a decision between Graff
grades or
putting out a mock draft three days
after this year's draft and and I said
you know what that I'll take the lesser
of two evils I just can't be the grade
but my least favorite project and my
most clicked-on thing on espn.com all
year long is that way too early mantra
I'm putting out on Wednesday there's is
it ready can you give me a morsel the
number one pick no you're gonna type er
so this is what happens it starts
tonight around pick 90 Piper's gonna
start nudging me and he's gonna be like
so who we thinking for quarterbacks who
the quarterbacks next year and then all
day Saturday and then we fly home on the
plane Sunday and that's when it gets
really weird cuz he he doesn't have he
can't sit still and he's rocking and
tapping his leg and so what do you think
inside linebackers this year first one
Justin Herbert make a mistake not coming
out no I don't think so
and it forget where he would have been
drafted even if he was a top-10 pick and
I know it sounds crazy because that's 20
to 30 million dollars guaranteed money
and yes you can get injured and there
are factors there but he was not ready
and you can tell yet in his play this
past year I think he just needs another
year and where you make your real money
come you know comparatively speaking
with in NFL money is if you get that
second contract and if you're not ready
you've seen how many guys just get
chewed up and spit out of this league in
four or five years and I think that he
would have been much more vulnerable to
that had he come out this year rather
than going back for another year and
just maturing your favorite milk hyper
eating story is what it used to be
pumpkin pie but that's stale I would go
my my new favorite is we go back to the
hotel every night and I ask him the same
question just as I want to laughs after
a long day he he will get the cheese
pizza and take the cheese off from room
service so it's now just basic it's the
crust and the tomato sauce and dip it in
mashed potatoes carb-loading you know
it's a long weekend I have a milk and
then what did you do with that right oh
man he's fascinating
is one of a kind like that that's where
he SPN was created for certain people
and Mel Kiper is one of those guys Halle
Schwab like what else would they do they
they have you know they had that vehicle
you know how we should still be there
but without ESPN what would Mel Kiper be
doing he'd be like a hairdresser I can't
wait to tell on that today have fun
tonight
Tod mache ESPN NFL Draft analyst for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app